hi sarah hello how are you
i am good i'm more curious how you are
but first i want to say congratulations
being a castaway on season 41 of
survivor i'm sure this was a dream come
true things clearly did not turn out how
you expected uh so what are the emotions
you're feeling today
you know it's definitely a roller
coaster i feel like it's a mixture of
emotions and like
it does suck a lot but i've received
such an outpouring of love support
everyone like seems really upset that
i'm gone so it's kind of nice that it's
like i feel like everyone's sharing the
sentiment and it's just
it is what it is like it's a part of the
game it's what we signed up for it's a
possibility and like obviously i would
have loved to have made it further but
you know it happens
you're right it happens and that's
that's all we can say right it's a game
you go into this knowing it's a game i'm
a bit pissed off as a fan because listen
we all saw you as this kind of sweet
intelligent you know
woman but i know there's a fighter in
there and i wish i had a chance to see
that do you wish viewers had a chance as
well
oh my god that's a thing that's so
frustrating it's like i really tried to
downplay it because i was like i don't
want people to realize like how much
like i'm a very driven person like if
you push me like i will push back and
like you kind of got an inkling of it at
that last tribal because i'm like going
into that like i knew it was me and i
was like there's no chance of how i'm
just gonna sit here and let myself get
voted out but it's like i'm glad that
you said you could see the fire because
like i'm you know
i feel it i have it getting voted out
this early has given me even more fire
and i just i want people to get the
chance to see it
well i think you know what i think
everyone has an idea like you said
online people are rallying behind you
they wanted to see more of you on the
show but just give me a little
give me a little idea of just how it
felt to be part of something like
survivor season one or 41. obviously
you're a huge fan of the show were you
just like mind blown when you got the
call
yeah getting the call
you know sitting on the boats like
those are just like
you know you can't take those memories
away from me like regardless of the
outcome and it's just like any time i
feel sad about it i just think about how
happy and like
you know that was just like peak life
moment in those moments of like can't be
taken from me regardless so it's like
i'm just happy with that and like i feel
like
you know yeah it was just a blessing to
be out there especially during covet as
well like because we might have like we
very easily could have just like not
filmed like if something went wrong or
people just positive but it's just like
yeah it was a blessing every day out
there with a blessing so
it's a true blessing now listen i have
to talk about some of the others on the
show i'm going to talk about brad first
brag is um you know brad was campaigning
right in front of you
to get you or shane off of there which
takes major balls to do that when you're
standing right there so like what are
your feelings towards brad at this point
um i mean obviously like it sucks when
someone throws your name out there it
sucks when someone votes for you but at
the end of the day like i can't say i
wouldn't i mean i literally was gunning
for him so it's like i can't blame him
for doing that because i literally was
gunning for him too so and we all sign
up for it's a game like at the end of
the day it's a game and i think it's
hard because emotions get involved you
build relationships with people but it's
like you know
i was
like shocked he threw my name out to me
and chan
i was excited because i'm like i have
leverage against someone now like can
you try to use this so
yeah it is what it is
and then there's another person ricard
uh you know a lot of people are calling
him a backstabber online would you say
that statement is true
you know i think
yeah i mean
you can backstop one person but have
loyalty to another obviously so it's
like
it is what it is he told me before
tribal he wasn't gonna write my name
down and looked me in the eyes and said
that and he still did but the thing is i
didn't believe him when he told me that
so it's like i think i would have been a
little bit more hurt by it if i
genuinely was like oh my god i believe
everything you're telling me but it's
like i feel like i saw right through it
and like
yeah it is what it is so
there's a lot of new twists this season
that fans are just like oh my gosh
they're uh shot in the dark yeah tell me
do you regret not using that is there
regret there now
so i think instantly you know i said
that at my exit confessional where i was
like i regret not playing it
he to the moment i did because going
into that tribal i was like i'm a
hundred percent gonna play this but then
obviously as you guys saw that tribal
was very live and very shaken up and i
didn't want to lose my vote so in the
moment i was like shoot like you should
have played that
but looking back at it now now that i've
had time to process it i don't regret it
for a second because i think you know
that tribal was closed and the last
thing i would have wanted to do was lose
my vote and like end up losing by a
margin of one and like sending myself
home essentially
um especially because the chance that
immunity is only one in six so
yeah i don't regret it but i mean it
could have been exciting but it is what
it is like yeah
it is what it is hindsight is 20 20. now
i have a kind of a two-parter question
for you the first part is
who do you think will win it all is
there a castaway in your mind at this
point in the game that you think will
win
i think at the moment i got voted out i
was like
i don't know
i think that's hard to say like i feel
like when i came out of the game because
i played for so short it was like you
didn't really know like you kind of get
voted on you're like what the [ __ ] just
happened like i don't like i don't know
these people and like the game is so
fast especially because the game was so
new as well this is a very new format
it's like
you really don't know who's gonna be
anyone's game at that point
it could be anyone's game is there
somebody that you
want to win though because that's a
different question
yeah so i think like that's also a hard
question for me to answer because it was
like i didn't meet anyone on other
tribes i only met uh people and like
they pretty much all voted for me genie
didn't vote for me i wanted genie to win
i think i just said that i was like
i want jeannie to win because it's like
she didn't vote for me so i feel like
that was valid
what do you think was like the hardest
part for you of being a part of survivor
season 41 it's a mentally and physically
challenging game you know like this is a
reality show but it really is difficult
yeah no i think also like coming out of
a time like quarantine when you're
literally so like i was very strict
about the quarantine obviously because i
lost someone to covey so like i'd only
socialize with my mother for a year
and then i'm going and like trying to
socialize with all these other people
like it was very jarring to just be like
completely out of your comfort zone like
but also so amazing to be a part of
something like this huge production like
people are rallying and honestly like
the energy was palpable like everyone
was just so excited to be there and just
to be a part of it and that it was
happening it was like
it just felt so special to be a part of
it and like
it's great being on the like i was so
psyched when i found out i was on 41
cause i'm like i'm gonna be on the
season that's on like you know right
after like they've been off the air for
a while too so it's just like and also
like the new era thing too i mean you're
literally like this is like
the and especially where it's something
like i feel like the fast pace of the
game is kind of what got me and it's
like i'm a part of like you know
i don't know just like the new the
changes in the game you're a part of
history you're part of survivor season
41. i gotta ask because jeff is like
this icon like you've seen him on tv for
40 seasons of survivor what was it like
that first time where you were kind of
standing in front of him were you just
like i'm here this is crazy yeah that's
the moment it felt real seeing jeff you
stop on the boat and it's like
oh my god like this is happening he says
go for that first challenge like you
don't have time to strategize like he's
literally saying go and the next thing
you know you're jumping off boats into
the ocean
it was like and the game was just go go
go and it's like as a super fan it's
just like
any time there like i said it's just
like
it was just a blessing like it was just
so exciting to be a part of
uh last question for you there has been
so many amazing castaways on survivor is
there somebody who you kind of
modeled or thought about while you
played the game
um i mean i definitely say like
one of the things i wanted to do like
had i made it further was like kind of
play like him because i feel like him in
her first season was like very much like
she'd make people feel like they were
making the decisions but like
she was really making the decisions or
like planning the ideas in their head
and i feel like that's a really smart
way to play
but like you know it really it works
well when like
you know like people don't get it but i
feel like
you know the caliber of playing and
survivor the caliber of players has
really increased like drastically over
the years and people are really with it
so yeah i don't think i would have tried
to play like her a little bit more but i
also i kind of just wanted to be like my
own i didn't want to try to fall into
like the pattern of playing like someone
else because like i feel like you can
really pigeonhole yourself with that
100 well congratulations again you were
part of history survivor coming back we
were so happy to see you on the show and
you should be proud of yourself i hope
you're feeling pride today yeah no i
definitely do and it's just exciting it
was exciting to watch still